when I find myself wondering like why
don't why aren't these shopkeepers armed
the three dudes walk in and they all
have guns on with them and I'm like the
shopkeeper is just him versus a bunch of
gun armed dudes like it makes me want
the shopkeeper to be armed and then I'm
like hoping he's able to defend himself
and it's like that I don't want to want
that but I'm that's what I want when I
see these people breaking and destroying
businesses I want these people they're
allowed us to survive what's that you
want order yeah I do want to order
that's the that's the impulse that ends
up having the right come in into place
because
Baron Trump is going to be like this
brutal I mean dictator have you ever
seen the red caesar no have you seen the
picture from the Denver Airport of the
kid with the iron fist you know I'm
talking about these these conspiracy
champions from Denver for sure let me
pull up these conspiracy theory
paintings Denver paintings
I'll show you man it's all it's all been
pre-planned